moderne technologien beschleunigen die
technische entwicklung immer mehr auch
die wissenschaft ist von dieser
beschleunigung betroffen war 2014 schon
ein unglaublich spannendes jahr für die
wissenschaft verspricht 2015 noch mehr
bahnbrechende erkenntnisse und erfolgen
welche das sind jetzt in klink zum
science fiction
das ende der epidemie der ebola ausbruch
2014 hat erschreckende ausmaße
angenommen
noch immer sieht es in vielen gebieten
nicht nach einer schnellen besserung aus
allerdings erwarten experten dass die
epidemie 2015 in guinea liberia und
sierra leone gestoppt werden kann erste
tests einer impfung gegen ebola werden
anfang 2015 durchgeführt die ergebnisse
sollen im juni vorliegen zusätzlich gibt
es schon jetzt erste versuche mit dem
blut der patienten die ebola überlebt
haben das blut soll eine besonders hohe
anzahl an antikörpern besitzen und
wissenschaftler hoffen auf diesem weg
eine heilung für die krankheit zu finden
trotz dieser aussichten warnen die
experten davor die krankheit außer acht
zu lassen ebola sollte weiterhin mit
oberster priorität behandelt werden ist
es wichtig menschen die an ebola krank
sind möglichst schnell zu finden zu
isolieren und zu behandeln
eine weitere hoffnung liegt auf dem
impfstoff gegen malaria der bereits 2013
in der testphase gute ergebnisse liefert
es wird erwartet dass der impfstoff im
laufe des jahres von der europäischen
arzneimittelagentur freigegeben wird
das würde den weg für afrikanische
länder ebenen den impfstoff zu
importieren und kindern im alter
zwischen fünf und 17 jahren zu geben wo
am besten wirkt besucher bei
zwergplaneten im laufe des jahres werden
sonden der nasa gleich zwei verschiedene
zwergplaneten erreichen und näher
untersuchen können im märz wird die
sonde dorn den protoplaneten cas
erreichen der sich im wasser ihnen wird
zwischen mars und jupiter befindet er es
ist der grösste gesteinsbrocken aus
ihren gürtel
wissenschaftler vermuten dass sich
gefrorenes wasser unter der küste
befindet
das missionsziel der sonde dawn ist es
die oberfläche zu fotografieren und sich
immer näher an den protoplaneten
heranzutasten um hinweise auf dessen
boden chemie zu erhalten
am 14 juli wird dann nach new york sind
sonder endlich flute erreichen neun
jahre lang ist die sonne geflogen hat
dabei fünf milliarden kilometer
zurückgelegt als sie losgeschickt wurde
war pluto sogar noch ein richtiger
planet die sonde wird bluetooth
atmosphäre seine oberfläche sowie seine
monde untersuchen da pluto bisher von
keiner einzigen raumsonde untersucht
wurde erwartet die nasa viele neue
erkenntnisse über die beschaffenheit
unseres planeten space ex landung noch
im januar wird das private
raumfahrtunternehmen spacex das auch die
ice s beliefert also die internationale
raumstation einen gewaltigen test
durchführen
die firma wird eine ihrer raketen die
falken nein in höheren
atmosphärenschichten aufsteigen lassen
um sie dann präzise auf einer zehn mal
zehn meter großen plattform im meer
landen zu lassen
diese methode würde den
gewinnorientierten unternehmen eine
möglichkeit geben ihre raketen wieder zu
verwenden und so gewaltige kosten zu
sparen
das unterfangen eine knapp 70 meter hohe
rakete senkrecht auf einer winzigen
plattform mitten im ozean landen zu
lassen ist unglaublich kompliziert und
space ex selber rechnet mit einer ex
volks chance von rund 50 prozent
im optimalfall wenn die methode jedoch
mit der zeit verbessert werden könnte
würden aus fliegen ins weltall
dramatisch billiger werden ob die rakete
sicher gelandet ist werdet ihr hier auf
youtube und auf unserem blog pixum de
erfahren mehr forschungsgelder 2015 ist
ein überwältigendes jahr für viele
wissenschaftler weltweit denn es werden
erstaunlich viele neue institute und
labore bereit gestellt in denen
geforscht und entwickelt werden kann in
london eröffnen gleich zwei institute
eines davon das 650 millionen pfund
teure francis crick institut wird über
1.200 mitarbeiter beschäftigen der
architekt lehnte die form des gebäudes
an ein chromosom an
passend zum biologischen schwerpunkt des
neuen instituts in seattle eröffnen 100
millionen teures forschungszentrum das
von microsoft mitbegründer paul allen
gestiftet wurde
dort wird vor allem nach stammzellen
geforscht die in der lage sind
herzgewebe zu ersetzen welches dann zum
beispiel in einem 3d drucker für
patienten hergestellt werden könnte und
auch die nasa kann sich freuen
sie erhält 2015 mehr finanzielle
unterstützung von der amerikanischen
regierung als sie überhaupt verlangt hat
400 millionen dollar zusätzlich sollen
in projekte gesteckt werden die uns
helfen unser universum besser zu
und das wird sich auch hier auf klicks
um niederschlagen erste ergebnisse von
hogan kilometer 2009 tauchte ein
möglicher beweis für die hypothese eines
fotografischen universums auf das geo600
experiment bei hannover sucht nach
gravitationswellen von schwarzen löchern
und stieß dabei auf ein rauschen nach
dem modell von craig hogan ist das der
beweis für seine theorie die
wissenschaftler sind über die
kleinstmögliche auflösung unserer
raumzeit gestolpert das ist
offensichtlich der fall gewesen um diese
theorie genauer untersuchen zu können
haben sie das honoriert das sind sehr
lange zwei sehr lange vakuum tunnel
durch die zwei lichtstrahlen fliegen sie
werden in der mitte geteilt spiegeln
sich am jeweiligen ende des tunnels und
treffen sich dann wieder in der mitte
und bilden die beiden laserstrahlen
interferenzen dann wäre das das rauschen
das gefunden könnte im frühjahr 2015
nach fünf jahren werden endlich die
ersten ergebnisse der versuche erwartet
wenn die versuche hoch ins theorie
bestätigen dann würde das bedeuten dass
unser universum und wir selber
projektionen sind mehr zu diesem
unglaublich spannenden thema findet ihr
in diesem video matrix sind wir nur
projektionen dafür eben hier klicken und
da unten gehts zum blog und zu recht mit
täglichen news allerdings natürlich wie
immer auch in der video beschreibung was
meint ihr
wenn sich auch die wissenschaft immer
schneller entwickelt was werden die
nächsten entdeckungen und erfindungen
sein
ab damit in die kommentare bis dann